coming all the way from New Zealand is
getting on a plane tomorrow so you need
to take them to hoping tonight yeah see
if this will wake up
thinking thinking thinking yes good okay
so thanks to Jared for inviting me I met
him at the bioconductor
conference in June last time I was in
New York and thanks for coming and so
I'm going to talk about the survey
package basically all the materials are
on github so first you know why should
you care about the survey package well
one of the big reasons to care about
multistage survey analysis is free data
the government and various other large
organizations spend an enormous amount
of money collecting data and then just
sticking it up on the web for you to use
so on health there's the National Health
and Nutrition Examination surveys
there's the National Health Interview
Survey there are more localized ones
like the California Health Interview
Survey I'm sure there are New York ones
as well there's the current population
survey which is where the unemployment
rate comes from there's surveys on
attitudes and how they change over time
like the General Social Survey and the
national longitudinal study of youth and
then there's the American Community
Survey which has got questions on just
about everything except as I found out
today religion which isn't in there for
some reason so there's a lot of free
data so the other thing is you might be
designing your own data collection and
want to do something a bit more
sophisticated than just picking people
at random however when you go and look
up what to do with these surveys when
you go to the documentation for these
surveys it comes with scary warnings
about how you you know don't try this at
home and so on you know they say that
it's standard statistical software
packages don't take into account all
this really important stuff and they
tend to get the wrong
they generally underestimate the
variance of a point estimate sometimes
substantially so and you don't want that
so and then if you try and look at
textbooks on survey analysis they have a
strong tendency to look like this and
you get you can sort of get the
impression that survey analysis is
primarily about the care and feeding of
subscripts so the there are a small
number of things that you actually do
need to know about surveys in order to
analyze them but most of the rest of the
stuff only the computer needs to know so
there are books textbooks full of
formulas those formulas are not
interesting now so some formulas are
interesting they explain how things are
done if you understand them it's really
helpful though e formulas in survey
textbooks are computational special
cases of the a general a very simple
general formula they're there in there
because the very general formula takes
time quadratic in the sample size and so
you need to have computational special
formulas but you don't need to think
about them
somebody's worked them out they've been
implemented and they're not interesting
they don't leave you don't learn
anything from understanding them there
are some things you do need to know and
so R is one of the good ways of doing
survey analysis data is another SATA has
very good survey support cess somewhat
unusually has never been the industry
standard and that's because there was
another sort of Fortran II or a program
called Soudan that was the industry
standard and that's been fading away a
bit recently so at least we don't have
SAS as the competition the competition
is really Stata
so there's three things you need to know
about weights clusters and straighter
weights you know they're well it's one
of these words that's overloaded in
statistics there are several different
meanings of weights and statistics what
it means in surveys a weight of a
hundred means this person represents a
hundred people in the population perhaps
you know the sort of canonical view of
this textbook view is that that means
you've sampled this person with a
probability one in a hundred but there's
a whole lot of other complicated things
that often go into the weights
non-response adjustments for people who
don't reply frame corrections for when
you've got this list of buildings but
the list of buildings is four years old
and some of them if he knocked down and
you ones have been built household size
correction telephones per household all
sorts of stuff but the weights generally
get given to you and so sometimes we
over sample groups of subgroups of
people and so they have smaller weights
because they're interesting so for
example a lot of the health studies over
sample racial and ethnic minority groups
because they're important and you
wouldn't learn enough about them if you
just sample people at random
sometimes you over sample because the
group is inexpensive so people working
for big companies get over sampled in
business surveys because it's easy to
make you know IBM or Google or whatever
fill in a survey you know where they
live whereas your local you know your
local papaya hot dog vendor it's a lot
harder to get all of them and so you
tend to take a small sample of small
businesses and all the big businesses
and sometimes it just happens as a sort
of an interesting side effect but the
weights are different then clusters if
you have to go and visit people so
sometimes you can just call people up on
the phone or email them whatever for a
survey but sometimes you actually have
to go in person to visit them to talk to
them or to take measurement you know
medical exams in some of these health
surveys and if you're doing that you
want them to be close together if you
want or if you're hauling around a
doctor's office with you in a big you
know set of four big tractor-trailer
trucks then you don't want to sample
5,000 people in random places around the
country because that's a lot of driving
you want to park these things and get
everybody you can locally and so you
have clustering you sample cities or
counties neighborhoods workplaces
schools whatever and you get less
information per observation that way
because all the people you get are you
know from New York or whatever but
putting one in the New York cluster but
you get more information per dollar and
so it ends up being worthwhile and then
there are straighter which are
relatively unimportant that they're one
of the things that distinguishes knowing
what they are distinguishes survey
people from other people so if you
sampled a thousand people from the US on
average you get ten from I or a true
from DC and but do there be random so
you you know you might get unlucky and
get no one from Iowa
so what you might do is to fix in
advance and say we're going to sample
exactly two people from Iowa ten people
from our air two from DC and so on and
those are then called straighter and
stratified sampling makes your sample
more representative of the population
and so you get more information per
observation so those are the three
things about surveys that you need to
know now that was sort of one stage of
sampling once you've sampled clusters
you if you sampled New York you don't
want to measure everyone in New York you
want a sub sample so you might sample a
bunch of neighborhoods in New York and
go there and then you might sample a
bunch of streets
in those neighborhoods and then go on
knock on doors there so you have
multiple stages of sampling fortunately
you can ignore this nearly all the time
and if you look at data people have put
up on the web public you
data it usually the datasets usually
pretend that there was just one stage of
sampling this is an approximation that
firstly makes it easier computationally
secondly makes it easier in terms of the
size of the files and thirdly helps with
confidentiality so everybody uses this
approximation they call it with
replacement sampling which is a terrible
name and it's that way for boring
historical Maps reasons so it when
people say with replacement what they
mean is this approximation and if you're
running your own survey you might know
about before you know for staged
sampling or whatever but if you're using
someone else's data you won't so the
survey package in one slide so there are
two steps you put your data into a
survey design object so you you tell are
what the sampling structure of your data
is and then that object then contains
all your data and also contains the
metadata about the sample survey
structure and you use that object where
you would otherwise use a data frame now
unfortunately big you can't just it
wasn't possible to just for example take
a function like LM and have a method for
when the data is a survey design object
because LM already has inheritance and
it's on the wrong argument it's on the
formula argue and so you know so before
because of the way all these functions
were set up the ones that have methods
and generics and so on it's necessary to
have new function names it's not
possible but the new function names
basically have a svy prefix so so they
mean does means so they GL am fits
generalized linear models and so on and
they take the way way most functions
would take a data equals argument that's
a data frame they take a design equals
argument that's why
these design objects and that makes sure
everything's kept together so it doesn't
get lost so now you know everything
about the survey package one of the
things that's relatively unusual about
it compared to other survey software is
there's a lot more support for data
exploration so in the old days sort of
official statistics people they knew
what tables they wanted to produce and
they went and produce those tables but
now if you're using these data for
modeling for data analysis then you want
to do the same sorts of data exploration
that you do with any data set and so we
want to make that possible and sometimes
that's easy putting the weights into
graphics so a box plot for example you
just need quartiles and so instead of
sample quartiles you can use estimated
population courthouse that's the
weighted estimates a histogram the box
height depends on the number of
observations in the box once you work
out the width and so on and instead of
the sample number you can use the
estimated population number a kernel
density estimate is just a sum of little
bumps little kernels and you can do a
weighted sum of little bumps so those
are all fairly straightforward what's a
bit trickier scatter plots so how do you
weight a scatter plot and there's a few
ways of doing this one if a really big
data sets is thinning you subsample the
data set down so that points with a high
weight sampled with low probability and
points with a low way to sampled with
high probability and that you end up
with a smaller data set that's sampled
with equal weight that sounds
inefficient in some ways it is but if
you're working with the American
Community Survey and you have two
million observations per year you can't
see that on a scatter plot any way you
could afford to you know thin it down to
a few thousand another way is to use the
Alpha channel of the picture to use
partial transparency so that a point
with no way
it is almost transparent at a point with
high weight is almost solid and another
way is hexagonal being where you
conceptually stick a hexagonal grid over
your scatter plot and squidge all the
points down to the center of a hexagon
usually you do this with the count of
points squid's them down you can do a
weighted count with the hexagonal bins
and I'll show some examples of these so
there's a survey plot function with a
type argument that says how you want to
do these and there's a range of options
the first one bubble plots are
traditional so there you make the size
of the plotting symbol proportional to
the weight and you could do worse but
it's actually not very good particularly
for large data sets because they will
end up on top of each other it's just a
mess back in the Stone Age what was the
best you could do okay so I'm going to
do a sort of worked example it's a
health data set very suitable given the
food we've been having so it's looking
at dietary sodium intake and blood
pressure in the in Haynes study so in
Haynes does health measurements it does
full medical exams they take blood
samples they do lab stuff to them it's
got it they interview you about you know
what you eat and when you go to the
doctor if you how healthy you are all
sorts of stuff so they measure
everything the way they tend to with
these big studies they sample about
15,000 people every two years and report
the data in two year waves it's one this
is the example I talked about where the
mobile examination center is for big
truck is towed around on four big trucks
and so they have I think they've got
four of them or maybe six of them but
they visit a fairly small number of
places
so they've got highly stratified
sampling they've got a very small number
of clusters the data is all out there on
the web the design is actually a
complicated four phase design but the
public use data pretends it's just one
one stage and so that's what we're going
to do so we need to set up the data this
is relatively boring it's just the main
point here the data comes in a whole lot
of sess transport files and you just
read them in and you know you could type
you could do this with pipes and tidy
versity stuff easily - I'm just old
there is a tidy verse wrapper for the
survey package called sewer SRV why are
and people who like that sort of thing
will find it's exactly the sort of thing
they like the so weights we're using the
data set comes with a whole bunch of
sets of weights depending on what sort
of data you're using here we're using
the dietary interview data so we need to
use the weights for that subs are
subsets of people the weights yep yep
no no they give you there's about twenty
or thirty little data tables and so this
is what this I'm doing here so here I'm
downloading there's a demographic data
table there's a blood pressure data
table there's a body measurements one
which has got BMI body mass index
there's a dietary recall one and there's
a whole bunch more and you down though I
downloading them and then I'm joining
them
so this merge is the old-fashioned join
data database join function in R so I'm
doing this here for the 2003 2004 wave
and here for the 2005 2006 wave and here
pasting those together into one big data
table and because that's two waves
pasted together it means the weights are
wrong so each wave has weights that add
up to the US population the US civilian
non-institutionalized population and but
you know she's got two waves they are up
to twice that much so I'm you know I'm
making a new weight that's just half of
the original weights there are also
people in the file who aren't in the
dietary interview so there's a big
everybody gets a clinical interview
where the doctors talk to you and ask
questions or probably nice nurses
torchic would ask questions
and but subsets of people get blood
samples or dietary recall whatever and
so there are people in the file who
aren't in our sample and those people
just don't exist through our point of
view
now the documentation tells us the
straighter and cluster variables they
call the clusters psus because that's
what survey people call them it stands
for primary sampling unit and you look
up in the documentation it tells you
that the variable called SD MVPs you is
the primary sampling unit and the
variable called s DMV straw is the
stratum identifier and I've got no idea
what s DMV stands for but it's what the
documentation says and I trust them so
we tell we say what are our sampling
like what are the unit identify as for
our sampling units so that's this ID
argument so it says that we're the
things we're sampling are these PS use
the sampling of the PS use is stratified
by the straighter and individual
observations are weighted by these
weights if we had multistage sampling we
would have multiple things here joined
together with a plus so we'd have the
sampling units at stage one plus
something units at stage two and so on
the data were only interested in the
subset of the data table where we have
that's in the the dietary sample that's
got a non missing weight and this is a
slightly annoying so when I wrote the
package I decided it would be a good
idea to have code to check that each
cluster was that in only one strata
because that's an easy error you could
make with your merging or whatever
unfortunately the national health
statistic
stands up Center for Health Statistics
calls all its clusters either one or two
and so there's a strata the cluster one
in every strata in the cluster two in
every stratum
so you have to disable the checking
otherwise I will tell you that cluster
one appears to be split across all the
strata and then so that returns an
object and that object knows has got the
data in it and it's also got the
structure metadata if you print the
object it tells you that it's a
stratified one level cluster sampling
design with replacement with 60 clusters
and you can think ask for things like
its column names and so on and you could
these are horrible names but they're
sufficiently consistent over time that
you can google them this is the secret
to how you I mean you could also read
the codebook it's actually easier to
just google them and let Google find the
codebook then a few minor data things
the dietary sodium and potassium a big
numbers in milligrams per day I'm going
to turn the little small numbers in
grams per day and also you know if I
were doing this in another country I'd
have them in malls or millimoles
whatever instead of grams SI units so
that's the update function so this is
like a a this just adds variables to
existing object then we can ask for
analyses so what's the mean sodium and
potassium intake from this design object
and the usual na RM equals true and the
mean for sodium is about three point
about three and a third mean for
classrooms about two and a half does
anyone know what the sort of recommended
maximum so do you mean take it what yes
well you see
yeah and then here Quantic or tiles so
there's again people are eating quite a
lot of sodium on average and we can so
you can get means you can get means from
subsets you may have if you encounter if
you read a little bit of survey analysis
sort of documentation whatever you'll
see warnings that you can't just subset
your data because that messes up the
sampling structure you can't just throw
away the data that's not in the subset
and you indeed you can't that the subset
function and the sort of square bracket
sub scripting all handle that properly
so the object does the right things when
you subset it what that means is it
doesn't necessarily get a lot smaller
when you subset it because it has to
keep a lot of the same information
conceptually what you do when you subset
is you set the weights for all the
observations outside the Sun set to zero
and then survey by you can look at here
we're looking at and you specify a
function set of variables you want to
analyze set of variables you want it
split up by and what you want done to
each one and here I'm asking for the
mean of sodium by race/ethnicity groups
and all the they're all quoted all the
variables are quoted with the twiddle
the model formula system I could have
used the tiny verse system except that
would have required time travel because
this is older than the tidy verse this
is how we used to do non-standard
evaluation back in the old days well the
tidy verse way is to have bear variable
names and then do some deep magic
underneath to quote them and then
unquote them it's it's nice for you it's
nice for straightforward database
operations it makes it easy
for new users but it sure sure makes it
hard for new programmers they are
simplified I mean they're doing a lot to
try and make it easier for programmers
but you know and that this is one of the
sort of questions of debate is is it
actually worth it is the benefit to new
users actually worth the cost to new
programmers whom traditionally the idea
was for s and R was that it lured you
down the slippery slope into programming
so if you do data analysis you end up
sliding bit by bit into coding and
that's harder now with the with all this
extra so you have to understand crazy
quotation which is an area of
programming that only a minority of
people have ever had to understand in
other languages so here's a scatterplot
this is a weighted scatterplot using hex
bins of diastolic blood pressure by age
I hope some people are looking surprised
so the thing about diastolic blood
pressure it goes it goes up and then
goes down again with age basically your
systolic goes up and keeps going up and
diastole it goes up and down again you
basically your arteries stop being sort
of rubbery and bouncy and just turned
into pipes and so the pressure is high
when the heart is pushing and low when
it's not so you can see here the nice
curve of the data you can see the
outliers you can see that person up
there who with a very high diastolic you
can see these people down here who look
a bit suspicious
so it's a good scatterplot for a lot of
purposes these people here it's not
precisely an error it's not an error in
the data it's when you if you've had
remember having your blood pressure
measured they pump up a calf and then
they listen as they let the air out
there's a change in the sound that marks
when your diastolic blood pressure and
the zeros are when they couldn't hear
the change in the sound and for these
people it's probably that the cuff
wasn't quite the right size and for
these people it's a mixture of the cuff
not being the right size and then having
very stiff arteries so this is a this is
a real phenomenon of the measurement
technology though obviously these people
do not have zero diastolic blood
pressure and then this is another
version of it with transparency and you
can see some things more easily and some
things less easily so the outliers
aren't as visible you can still see
these zero people but you can see the
top coding of age more obviously so top
coding is another thing survey people
official statistics people do everybody
85 85 means 85 or older which is why
there's this extra so the scatter plots
are useful and the different approaches
show you different things okay so some
smoothers here so survey smooth we've
got blood pressure against age for men
and for women the shapes are similar but
men's blood pressure Peaks younger and
higher slightly or quantile smoothers so
here we've got survey smooth and there's
a method argument that says you want
quantile regression instead and we get
regression quantiles which i think is a
good way of looking at the distribution
of the conditional distribution of a
variable
okay and then a regression example I'm
going to do logistic regression with the
outcome variable isolated systolic
hypertension which means that your
systolic blood pressure is high but your
diastolic isn't it's something that
happens to older people almost everybody
ends up with isolated systolic
hypertension
whereas middle-aged people tend to end
up with both systolic and diastolic
being high
okay so we've defining a variable that
says that your systolic blood pressure
is high and your diastolic isn't well
I'm defining some linear splines in age
because we obviously don't want a
straight line relationship with age
that's the point of the scatter plots if
you haven't seen this is so I like
linear splines when talking to medical
people because they're easy to interpret
the slope the coefficients of slopes in
different parts of the range you don't
get quite as good fit as you do with
cubic splines but no one the only thing
you can do with lyric splines has drawn
a picture of them and a lot of medical
people don't like you doing that with
regressions and we've got a set of
models being built up from the very
simplest just age to ones that have got
age gender interaction race ethnicity
and sodium intake and that all looks
just like you do with GL M except that
you've got a design argument instead of
the data argument the family quasi
binomial that suppresses a harmless but
annoying warning I will warn you of with
binomial if your weights are the
integers and it doesn't matter it
doesn't affect the results at all if you
put crazy binomial instead of crazy
binomial it's just you get this annoying
warning
so here's a analysis of variance
building up the model without just the
absorber adjustment model with age
gender race/ethnicity interaction
likelihood ratio tests and so on these
are new these likely these are the rail
Scot likelihood ratio tests they're
basically the idea is that the
likelihood ratio doesn't have a
chi-squared distribution but it's still
a statistic it has a distribution and
you can work out what its distribution
is and do tests that's fine
the that's statistic that's its design
effect which says you know this looks
big but it's not as big as it looks
because it's a noisy thing we've got a
comparison of the models with and
without sodium with a deeply
unimpressive p-value there's very little
evidence that sodium matters which is a
bit disturbing so we can try some more
variables perhaps you know so adjusting
for body mass index as well stick
potassium intake in there because
they're sort of related sort of issue
and again deeply unimpressive p-value
okay so maybe it's non-linearity so we
can stick in some splines in sodium
intake and we can do a test again for
these for that pair of terms and go back
and again but that doesn't seem too much
going on there there's a number the
reason this is looks like this is
because self-reported dietary data is so
crap so people who do this if you want
to do this sort of thing seriously
you get replicate measurements you do
measurement here or modeling and you
could do all that with the survey
package - it's just that I'd have to
explain regression calibration and stuff
and it would take another half hour but
that's the may that's the the reason
that we're not seeing a relationship is
maybe there's a fairly are we leaving
outside questions of causality there's a
fairly robust correlation between sodium
intake and hypertension but we can look
at a continuous outcome so here's
systolic blood pressure as a continuous
variable and we're doing just a linear
model so we just lead out the family
option the default is Gaussian is a
linear model and now we see that there
is modest but reasonable evidence that
sodium and potassium matter and we could
look at the coefficients again this is
just like a generalized linear model any
generalized linear model and we're
seeing that sodium coefficient is
positive and the potassium one is
negative as that's all as it should be
that's oh very nice and we might feel a
bit relieved except that these are
really small numbers so this is the
difference in millimeters of mercury per
1 gram difference in sodium intake a
gram difference in sodium intake is a
lot and a millimeter of mercury blood
pressure difference is very small so
what we're seeing here is statistically
robust but
meaningless from a health point of view
associations and again this is largely
the measurement error problem if we'd
ignored the survey design though so so
we suppose we just a linear model for
that for blood pressure without weights
or anything then the ratio so this is
the ratio of the wrong to the right
regression coefficients and it's quite
wide and this is the ratio of the wrong
to the right standard errors and you see
they're underestimated by an amount that
you'd care about you know 1/2 to 1/2 to
1/4 so it does make a difference taking
the survey design into account other
things we can do
ordinal logistic regression so the
proportional odds model survival
analysis log linear models for
contingency tables rank tests if you
must do rank tests at least you can do
design based ones that a proper that do
the thing they're trying to do properly
AIC in bi C we invented how to do AIC
and bi c for weighted model comparisons
and then sometimes you get designs
specified by sets of basically bootstrap
or jackknife weights so they don't tell
you the survey design information they
just give you a set of jackknife weights
that sort of encapsulate it and you can
do that and then there's functions to
rescale your weights to match known
population information then
you'd start a bit low and we're running
yes okay so and then very briefly
two-phase sampling so this is a more
sophisticated problem so here you've got
a data set that you've got a database or
a cohort study or something and then you
want to go and measure some more
variables on a subset of the people
because it's too expensive to measure
them on all the people
it's called two-phase sampling the word
phase versus stage means that the
sampling is allowed to depend on the
values of the data that you've really
measured this doesn't affect any of the
computations but it does affect what the
Greek letters mean in those computations
so survey mathematical survey
statisticians think it's very important
that you distinguish between phase and
stage possibly even more so because it
doesn't affect any of the computations
they're examples a trivial example is
case control sampling where you sample
everybody who has a binary out the
binary outcome positive and a small
subset of the people who don't have it
there's a technique where you take a
random subset of people and then add all
the disease cases later or cases of
whatever it is for cases whatever it is
you're analyzing or you know if you've
got an outcome variable and exposure
variable or sort of surrogates for them
the approximations to them you can
sample based on both and you get a more
complicated sampling design with
possibly more efficiency gain so this
sort of two-phase sampling there's lots
of opportunities to think about optimal
design especially if you don't have a
non-response problem so often when we're
doing this we're taking for example
taking free text responses people have
given us and in hand coding them or
taking blood samples people have given
us and sending them off to the lab and
so non-response isn't really a problem
and so it's actually worth thinking
carefully about design
anyway so here's an example we've got
what do we we need to say this is a data
set from a children's cancer study and
we have to say you know that this two
phase function looks basically like the
survey design function except there's
two of everything so there's a so the ID
we need to say what the sampling units
are at phase one and phase two we need
to say what the straighter are at phase
1 and phase 2 when we also need to say
what the weights are at phase one and
phase two except here the weights at
phase one are just equal which is the
default and we don't need to tell are
the weights at phase two because I can
work it out for the itself there's a
sort of general principle that you don't
let users enter data that the computer
can work out because the users will get
it wrong so and again it just looks the
same the analysis if these two phase
samples just looks the same as you just
have a different sort of design object
and you plug it into the slot that takes
design objects but you can see if you
print them out that they're more
complicated
the other thing this shows his post
stratification so if you take a survey
take a sample and then there may be some
known population totals that you want to
match so if you're doing a survey of
people then you might want to match the
census totals before say age sex and
race or if you're doing a sample from a
cohort that you control there's all
sorts of data you have that you might
want to match the estimates of and you
get more information by forcing your
sample to match you make it more
representative and so this is the fourth
thing this is a the fourth thing about
surveys which is not a thing you need to
know but it's a thing that it's
sometimes useful to know is that you can
force a sample to be more representative
by rewriting it slightly and this is
what the calibrate function is for and
you tell it what variables you want to
calibrate to generally you also need to
tell it what those true totals are in
this case you don't because in the
two-phase sampling it knows them already
it's got that if it's data set yes
that's right so it optimizes the weights
and it's it's very widely used for
reducing non-response bias so this is
how opinion polls in the electoral
opinion polls for example aren't
completely useless despite response
rates of a couple of percent but you
connect yeah and it's got different
names I think it's there's something
called rim weighting I think in
marketing and so there's different names
for it in different different fields
calibrate is actually a terrible name
because again if namespace collision
problems there are too many things
called calibration in statistics
okay so adding features there are a lot
of features in the package but people
keep wanting more which is good the best
way to get features that you want added
to the packages to ask for them because
I don't know what you want I will add
features that I think are interesting
but that might not be what you want
and ideally ask with a you know a
published paper describing the estimator
exactly so I know what you're asking for
and a test data set so I can tell
whether I've got it right but you know
sometimes I do get requests but from
people saying you should implement this
thing and when I look at the I do a sort
of Google search whatever it turns out
that nobody's worked out how to do it
but yet and that's why I haven't
implemented it and in that situations I
may just work out how to do it and
that's how we got AIC and BRC and the
ranked tests you know somebody emailed
saying why don't why don't you have you
know why why doesn't the survey package
do wilcoxon tests and you know because
nobody's invented them yet but okay I
think about it one thing that that won't
be so effective for mixed models turn
out to be really hard partly for non
obvious reasons I mean this one
reasonably intuitive issue which is that
mixed models are balancing a bias
variance trade-off in estimating random
effects and the bias-variance tradeoff
is different in the sample and in the
population but there are also other
things like where do you even stick the
weights in the estimator
so mixed models are hard and I'm working
on them but other things are more likely
to be able to be just implemented so
where do you find all this stuff
the cran the survey packages on cran the
development repository for it is on our
Forge I'm on Twitter I have a blog which
also has random bits of
technical stuff about the survey package
on it from time to time the survey LMA
the mixed model code that's in
development is on github these slides
are okay oh well because the main I mean
the sort of motivations for rank tests
are typically I mean firstly that they
they're exact even in small samples
which isn't true of the design based
versions and secondly that they sort of
outlier resistant and that's going to
depend on the weights on what the
weights are like in so there and also
the survey data is typically large
enough that you know completest is
nonparametric as well so there are also
things that the RAM they're sort of
weird the other thing about rank tests
is they're not transitive which is a
weird technical property but if you've
got three groups a B and C then the
wilcoxon test can tell you that a is
higher than BB is higher than C and C is
higher than a and you know that's all
the rank tests except for tests for a
single quant I'll do that and I think
it's a sort of unfortunate property so
it's a mixture of those things
I know
so if you want to you need to do some
work there are two relatively
straightforward ways to do it and I've
got blog posts describing it one is if
you have replicate weights these
jackknife type and rep weights there's a
with replicates function that runs any
code you supply using the sets of
replicate weights so if you know how to
do any sort of weighted zero inflated
estimator then you can do a properly
survey so they waited one the other
thing is there's a function survey MLA
which you give it a you give it a log
likelihood or other objective function
and it will go and optimize it for you
so and it knows you know it knows how to
put in linear predictor so if you wanted
to do linear regression which obviously
don't you'd give it the standard normal
likelihood and tell it to stick a linear
predictor on the MU argument and so if
we look at
the I've got I had a good example of
this but unfortunately it belongs to
John Wiley & Sons which was implementing
negative binomial regression and I'm
going to put in some other count models
either myself or where I can get a
student to do them but here we've got a
censored log-normal example where you
specify that's a sense of normal
likelihood you that's its derivative and
then you just say use that log
likelihood for each observation and
stick a linear predictor with those sick
pose predictors a linear predictor on
the mean variable and just a constant on
the standard deviation variable so that
again will that will let you implement
things and you can probably get
something that's a bit more
computationally efficient with more work
but those two approaches will work for a
lot of things
yep
to some extent tests paper we went and
searched on wilcoxon and in Haines as
keywords and there are a lot of people
who are doing the ordinary wilcoxon test
on in Haines basically nowadays if
they're doing something that their
software has a convenient survey
analysis for they're likely to do it
that way the main I think the main
exception to this is the General Social
Survey where people I think people do
tend to analyze that without taking the
design into account in Haines I think
they're more likely to do it right when
that's easy but they may well not notice
when it's hard
there ii would not it depends on the
there isn't a sort of specific limit but
you end up the theory says that it that
it should be small compared to the
square root of the number of
observations and that's all about all
the theory says experience sort of
simulation experience says that things
will it will obviously start looking bad
before the estimates break down so
you'll get more efficiency and then
you'll start getting less efficiency and
that will happen before everything
breaks down and stops being valid but so
it's fairly safe to add variables until
it if it looks like it's helping it
probably is helping but there isn't
there isn't any satisfactory theory
yep okay so the simplest okay the
simplest mental model for them is a
jackknife so you okay so how the ACS the
American Community Survey publishes
these replicas Thwaites and you know how
basically do they work so if you think
of a jackknife or a bootstrap so a
bootstrap people familiar with bootstrap
variants when you take a bootstrap
sample you get some observations once
some observations 0 times some
observations twice and so you could
write that as a set of weights where an
observation that isn't included gets
away to zero an observation that's
included once gets a weight of one
observation that's included twice gets a
weight of 2 and so on and so you can
write if you had like a hundred
bootstrap samples you could write that
as a hundred columns of bootstrap
weights and if you multiply them by the
original weights you'll get survey
bootstrap weights now because of cluster
sampling the things your bootstrapping
aren't individual observations they're
clusters and because of stratification
you there's some tricky things about how
you do the resampling within structures
within straighter but that's the basic
idea now the ACS uses so it uses a type
it's based on a design that has two
clusters per stratum and their
bootstrapping basically says you're
going to split the data in half you'll
get so you'll get two independent data
sets that have one cluster per stratum
and that's the sort of and then
that's something called BRR waving as it
turns out that's a little and then you
have to look at all the possible ways
you can split you know you're splitting
each stratum independently and there's
lots of possible ways you could do that
and you want to pick a carefully
engineered set of them that picks up all
the possibilities that is balanced in
all the right ways and they're things
called Hadamard matrices appear in this
and so it's relatively complicated in
detail but the basic idea is that it's a
bootstrap and that's what the ACS
weights are they give you a tea sets of
weights and they are conceptually
a well-designed bootstrap sample at the
cluster level h1 and then so you
evaluate your estimator for each one of
those 80 things and then you take the
variance of those 80 estimates and then
there's a scale factor of 1/4 for
complicated reasons and that's your
variance estimator the scale factor of
1/4 is because each of these things is
only half as big as the original data
and that's how the the methyl comes out
but so it's basically a tea bootstrap
samples that they've given you and
giving everyone the same a tea bootstrap
samples firstly it means that they can
make sure they're nicely balanced so you
don't end up with any unlucky bootstrap
samples and secondly it means that
everybody will get exactly the same
answer whereas if you were doing
bootstrapping with only 80 replicates
everybody would get slightly different
answers and official statistics don't
like people don't like that because it
leads to you know people saying oh you
don't get the same you don't get the
right answer my answer is this your
answer is that yeah and that causes
paperwork and hassle and so for what as
they say face validity reasons they try
to avoid that and so they published
their replicate weights they don't let
you they don't encourage you to generate
them yourselves
yeah so the question is about what do
you do if you don't really you get the
date or you don't really know what the
sampling strategy and the weights and so
on were the probably the I think what I
would do is to see what it if possible
if it was possible to calibrate it to
some external data then that would be a
good way of getting more reliable
weights you do need to know whether what
the something units were so what did you
sample individuals or did you sample you
know school classrooms or whatever but
you should know that if you don't know
that you're in trouble and so so for
example there's a nice exercise in
Sharon laws survey textbook that's a
survey that was done by the American
Statistical Association of its
membership to ask how people felt about
having a chartered statistician
qualification and it didn't come with
any weights but they know they know
demographic information about the people
who responded and about the Association
as a whole and so you can then use that
information to work out weights that
would scale the sample to be
representative of the Association as a
whole so that's an example of something
that should have was done it should have
been done better given that it was the
American Statistical Association but
that it could be rescued by calibration
to a known set of totals and I think
that's the sort of thing that could be
quite useful for sort of wide variety so
traditionally the art people got upset
when you talked about doing this to
things that weren't really probability
samples but so for example you have the
survey organization that's their
methodology is to collect rich
calibration information and get a big
sample and not to worry about any of
this probability sampling stuff and to
just say you know you're going to you're
going to model the sampling process
statistically and it seems to work and
you know basically all
telephone pole sampling really relies on
that sort of calibration stuff because
nobody gets useful response rates
nowadays so if your if your random digit
dialing you know which used to be the
sort of gold standard way of getting
samples if your random digit dialing
works it works because your non-response
Corrections are good because even things
like in Haines and the the equivalent
health telephone surveys where you know
people that they put a lot of money into
sampling and people are relatively
willing to help the BRFSS the telephone
health survey it's got a response rate
just over a half and they you know
that's when they do sort of twenty or
thirty callbacks if they can to try and
get to people and you know and people
actually like participating in that sort
of well more like more than they do in
you know in actual opinion polls and so
that sort of thing works it clearly
works in well-designed samples with
non-response and so it probably works in
poorly designed samples with
non-response and there's some empirical
evidence both from YouGov and from some
studies of different calibration
approaches to this telephone health
survey there's some evidence that it
really does work
but traditional survey statisticians
hate people saying things like that
because the idea of probability sampling
is fundamental and it is it's just you
can't do it anymore for by telephone so
most of what I do the sampling is you
know is this sort of two-phase sampling
where you don't have non-response
problems you can do beautifully designed
waiting and waiting really works there
it's wonderful that the when you've just
got response rates of 5% and dealing
with the public and so on then you're
going to be relying on modeling lis
response process and you just want as
much information as you can get about it
and that's where sort of predictive
machine learning approaches and so I
might actually be useful to incidentally
there's a conference called big serve an
annual conference that is basically does
that sort of thing so what can you what
useful things can you do with predictive
modeling and big data to help with
survey problems past yes appears to well
if it depends on how you start there's a
sampling question it's not a question
about the population there are a
multinomial logistic regression
available no but it would be relatively
straightforward to add I think because
so there are various packages that have
gotten you know a non survey one it
should be fairly easy to add
with oh it's the most exciting thing
I've done with the package
[Laughter]
exciting I mean it's not really exciting
isn't really the right word I mean
there's certainly I mean they're so
they've been you know visit it you know
it's been visiting you know people
survey organizations and you know seeing
that they're actually using it as you
know so when I found out that the
Italian official statistics agency and
the Portuguese official statistics
agency were using it you know that that
sort of thing is nice and some of the
and some of the research stuff is fun
but I wouldn't precisely say exciting
yes but you know I mean it's so it is
really I mean seeing that seeing people
in serious official statistics
organizations using it and going and
talking to them about it and well you
know what which bits of it they would
would like and which bits of it they
change because I you know I'm relatively
well when I started doing this I was
sort of new to the field I wasn't a
survey statistician and historically
there a bit protective of their field
they don't want mathematical
statisticians parachuting in and saying
aha
we can solve all this all all of this
with by considering polynomial hyper
admissible estimators or whatever so get
though you know it takes a while to sort
of get accepted by them as somebody
who's probably okay who you want to give
this to no dear that's not fair well if
it's supposed to be on most difficult
well most difficult question from a sort
of technical point of view would be the
what happens if you don't know what your
survey design was so
oh sorry
Oh missed lady not as aerodynamic as the
leader teacher leader teacher may had
one at our studio briefly yes